you know most of it is when I want to do
something on a computer and there's not
either there's not a way or there's not
a good way or there's not a free way to
do it so it comes out of wanting to use
the thing that I'm making ultimately and
then once once it becomes a something of
its of its own I think having other
people use it is actually very rewarding
in that you get satisfaction from other
people getting the same benefits that
you are from the software that you may
there are 13 people where I've looked at
the work they've done and had a lot of
respect for them and like John Carmack
would be an example who was one of the
founders of Ede software who made like
doom and quake and Wolfenstein 3d and it
was always it was always impressive to
look and see the things that they would
produce and that they would be
successful doing it and and apparently
enjoy themselves so that would be one
top of my head example also in in like
the 90s and probably maybe before that
as well there was a big demo scene where
people would make demos where it would
be trying to demonstrate what would be
possible with the limited computers of
the time and most of these people were a
European I think but they would have
these big parties where they would show
off their demos and a lot of those guys
I don't remember specific names but it
was always impressive the things that
they could accomplish
say that there are best programmers but
I think that there are programmers who
end up being probably 10 times more
productive than a sort of average
programmer and I don't know what it
would really take I think it's it comes
down to it comes down to just the
ability to cut through what's really
important and then focus on that and
sort of having the the sense to know
that when you get that stuff right
everything else can fall into place and
there's probably some some necessary
element of being able to keep enough
things in your head at the same time but
I think really a lot of it's just sort
of a signal to noise if you find the
right thing to focus on it makes
everything alright
I think a lot of it comes down to it's
very easy to spend a great deal of time
focusing on something and and then
forget to call your friends and that
sort of thing it's I probably would do
that more if I wasn't married so but
yeah I think I think there are
programmers that way but I think there
are plenty of programmers who are just
like regular people and do regular
things and go out and you know do all
the things that are sort of normal ish